see if I remember if ladies
I don't oh my god
we're back with skate three are you
excited Bob damn look at that [ __ ] bomb
actually nail the trick yeah
what oh god what if puck do you come
from destroy him
must destroy he's way too fast
get him in under the car let's go baby
rekt [ __ ] I call this one Olie over the
card jesus [ __ ] christ
whoa [ __ ] me and my meatballs okay me
like a meatball we clawed we chained our
hearts in never MIFA I'm Bob [ __ ] I'm
Bob Wow I'm so yeah
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba Hey Baby how you
doing
ah [ __ ] ah my skateboard is pissed
ah a biscuit whoa Jesus Christ ha ha I'm
gonna be magical they told me I could
become anything sir I became a spy oh
[ __ ] it happen again
uh uh hey girl how you doing I just
couldn't make it away downtown walking
fast faces pass and I'm home bound
this is how we skate in Sweden [ __ ]
cálmate cálmate place she's not one
calmate please tell me ah oh
my dad
Oh Bob's in the house
peppermint bouncing house but bouncing
house but Bob's in house Bob hey girl
are you doing with them you back that
baby
Oh notice me notice me taste me [ __ ]
chase me ah [ __ ] love it do it again
I have it keep chasing me I'm a tree
[ __ ] I'm a tree whoa whoa whoa
what's happening ha ha ha ha ha trains
bench manche manche manche manche manche
manche manche manche manche manche
ah [ __ ] I'm I'll kill myself Bob oh [ __ ]
Bob you make sure they remember
forever the night they played tapes
ha ha ha ha what didn't you guys like to
stand on a bench instead I want badges
[ __ ] oh I love inches problem benches
every page whoa ha ha ha
around a night experience a benefit of
target acquired oh [ __ ]
target acquired
[ __ ] target acquired
go [ __ ] oh hell destro ha ha ha Bobby
like were you talking to [ __ ]
yeah that's right [ __ ] F [ __ ] your wife
I don't have a wife
[ __ ] but I pad ffffff mmm hey baby ah
damn it that's what you get for loving
benches ha ha ha hey man you want to go
on a date
all right see you later
yes oh jeez
what's happening ha ha ha ha I'm a tree
all right breasts
it looks like well I'm doing it there I
had a lot of fun playing with your birds
today leave a like if you want most
skate three and I will see you browse
and the next one as always stay awesome
fresh Star Wars Episode two senpai
Strikes Back
senpai I brought this present I brought
this for you
don't run I love you target acquired
Ben Showtime yeah yeah oh my god is
robbed Iraq